Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est le nouveau master class
et dans ce nouveau master class
Je vous parle de mnémotechnie
Avec la mnémotechnie, vous allez améliorer votre capacité à retenir des choses,
à retenir plein d'informations qui n'ont pas forcément de sens comme des listes de choses par exemple
Ça, ça n'a pas de sens
Des exemples valent mieux que de longs discours
donc je vous donne quelques exemples
Et le premier, c'est moi
Vous avez forcément déjà tous entendu parler de cette expression : "Mais-Ou-Et-Donc-Or-Ni-Car"
Et j'en ai bouffé quand j'étais petit...
C'était pas facile vous savez...
"Mais-Ou-Et-Donc-Or-Ni-Car" ça permet de retenir les conjonctions de coordination
Ça fonctionne parce qu'il y a une petite musique derrière
Il existe d'autres procédés pour faire ça, comme par exemple les phrases
avec un secret caché à l'intérieur
"Monsieur, vous tirez mal, je suis un novice pitoyable."
Avec la première lettre de chacun des mots vous allez retenir l'ordre des planètes dans le système solaire
Donc "monsieur vous tirez mal" ça donne le M pour Mercure, vous c'est le V pour Vénus
Tirez c'est le T pour Terre
mal c'est le M de Mars
"Je suis un novice pitoyable", Jupiter
Suis: Sature
Un : Uranus
Novice: Neptune
et le P de Pluton, parce qu'à l'époque,
on croyait que Pluton faisait partie du système solaire
et puis,  bon
y'a eu des colloques
et des discussions
bref, Pluton
EXIT !
Là c'est une phrase complète évidemment
Mais ça aurait pu être aussi un seul mot
Composé avec toutes les lettres qui nous intéressent
Comme dans le code mnémotechnique de Vibujor
Vibujor! Vous connaissez pas Vibujor?
Vibujor c'est l'ordre des couleurs de l'arc en ciel
Le V pour Violet
Le I de Indigo, le B de Bleu
Le U de Vert.
Oui U Vert
C'est simplement que quand
on écrit Vibujor
en fait le U ça peut avoir la forme un petit peu d'un V
et ça permettait d'avoir une voyelle
Évidemment "JOR" vous avez compris c’était
Jaune Orange et Rouge
Donc avec un seul mot on retient encore une fois
une liste d'information en plus dans un ordre précis
qui nous intéresse. Dans les procédés
mnémotechniques intéressants il y a aussi le fait de cacher en fait
des nombres à l'intérieur des mots à l'intérieur
de votre processus comme dans le
légendaire poème : "Que j'aime à faire apprendre
Un nombre utile aux sages !"
Ce qui ce cache à l’intérieur de ce poème c'est tout
simplement Pi et les décimales de Pi
Le nombre de lettres de chaque mot
correspond à une décimale de Pi dans le
bon ordre évidemment. "Que j'aime à faire apprendre",
si on compte le nombre de lettre de chaque mot ça fait
3,14159
9 pour "apprendre" après 2 puisque c'est "un"
vous pouvez regarder d'ailleurs sur internet
si vous voulez apprendre le poème en entier
et connaître encore plus de décimales
il y a une suite à ça évidemment
"Immortel Archimède, artiste ingénieur,
Qui de ton jugement peut briser la valeur"
les procédés mnémotechniques peuvent aussi servir dans
le quotidien pour des détails pour la vie de tous les jours
Bientôt on sera au mois d'Avril
Et au mois d'Avril on change d'heure
Et alors est ce qu'on avance d'une heure
ou est-ce qu'on recule d'une heure au mois d'Avril?
Avril ça commence par "AV" comme "AVANCE"
L'autre changement d'heure il est en octobre
et "OCTOBRE" sa finit par "RE" comme "RECULER"
Donc en AVril on AVance et en octobRE on REcule
Dans le même état d'esprit il y a évidemment les stalagmites qui montent parce qu'il y a un "m"
et les stalactites qui tombent avec le "t".
A l'époque du changement des francs à l'euro, j'avais aussi trouvé un moyen mnémotechnique comme pour celui de pi.
J'ai oublié de le dire là il y a quelques secondes, c'était la phrase : "Chacun saura enfin convertir notre monnaie."
Le nombre de lettres de chaque mot correspondait au taux de conversion de l'euro au départ.
Au changement de monnaie.
Donc 6,55957
Je vous ai donné ces exemples là pour vous montrer que ça s'appliquait à un petit peu tout.
Il y a réellement plein de techniques différentes, plein de processus en fait, de méthodes pour créer de la mnémotechnie.
Et trouver de la logique dans ce que vous avez à apprendre, surtout quand c'est une accumulation de choses qui n'ont pas trop de sens
comme tout les noms des rois de France, si vous devez apprendre tout les noms des rois de France,
il vaut mieux se créer une phrase ou un jeu ou un mot un peu comme vibujor.
La mnémotechnique en fait c'est un moyen qui va permettre de faciliter la récupération des informations qui sont dans votre cerveau.
C'est à dire que vous savez des choses, vous les avez apprises, c'est quelque chose que vous avez rellement imprégné.
Et votre moyen mnémotechnique c'est un petit peu votre rail, votre guide pour ça.
Ça peut faciliter, un petit peu comme un aide-mémoire, des informations un peu binaires ou ternaires.
Vous savez comme là pour octobre et avril. Est-ce qu'on recule, est-ce qu'on avance ?
Les meilleurs procédés mnémotechniques que vous pouvez utiliser c'est ceux que vous inventez pour vous avec votre logique à vous et vos méthodes à vous.
Je vous incite à le faire, c'est l'objet de ce master class aujourd'hui,
vous allez augmenter au moins par deux la manière dont vous allez trier les choses dans votre cerveau, la manière dont vous allez créer votre dossier dans votre disque dur mental.
Alors vous allez commencer à organiser vraiment votre mémoire et à devenir hyper efficace là-dedans !
Et c'est ce que je souhaite évidemment !
Vous savez que vous pouvez aussi sous-titrer cette vidéo (ce que je viens de faire: Z1proW)
si vous avez quelques minutes ou plutôt quelques heures, c'est toujours un peu long à faire...
J'ai ouvert les sous-titres des vidéos, vous pouvez sous-titrer celle-ci.
Ou, très utile aussi : corriger les fautes d'orthographes qui se cachent dans les sous-titres collaboratifs qui ont été faits par d'autres abonnés ou peut-être même par vous-mêmes !
Merci à tous d'avoir fait ça ! Vous passez du temps dessus ! C'est un truc, vraiment ça me touche, ça me fait plaisir que vous fassiez ça. Top !
Voilà, là c'est moi qui vous met un pouce en l'air !
Mais p'têt que vous êtes en train de faire pareil pour cette vidéo...
Je serais ravi qu'à la fin de cette vidéo vous vous abonniez à la chaîne,
j'ai un petit moyen mnémotechnique pour pas que vous oubliez :
Cliquez ici tout de suite, comme ça vous n'oublierez pas de le faire.
Ça permet de faire encore plus connaître la chaîne à encore plus de personnes.
Passez un excellent week-end et rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain mental vlog, Ciao !
* Sous-titré par des abonnés <3 *